distilled spirits make up more than 35%
of the US market for alcoholic beverages
now consumers are trading up by spending
more on small volume products made by
specialists many generation family
proprietors Michael Quintus is the
president and the chief executive of
Ventus they're the exclusive u.s.
importer of Tesoro cognac he explains
the growth of premium cognac in the
United States the cognac category is an
important category it's about 4 million
cases in the United States it's a 1 and
a half billion dollar business and it's
a very traditional business of course
cognacs have been around for centuries
and in the US market it's always been an
important category the category itself
the cognac category is dominated by four
major houses which remi martan Corvo ACA
Martell Hennessy and they dominate they
control about 90% of the total cognac
market in the United States and they
specialize primarily in an introductory
level cognac CVS and VSOP that's the
largest share of the overall Conneaut
business the minority share the angel
share almost for the category is in the
exo grade and these are cognacs that are
aged for at least 10 years in barrel
only currently the laws six years
actually but in 2016 effective with 2016
the requirement will be 10 yrs and this
is where tessarin has decided to
specialize its business it's not
interested in the introductory category
we're in the luxury business and that's
the focus of our cost these days when it
comes to tests around cognac well we're
going to look at three of the special
category of wines in the test run range
known as the Signature Collection the
introductory one is called XO passion
and that would cost $300 to a consumer
the next is over 750 milliliters okay
that's correct our next level up would
be the extra legend also EXO and that
would be $500 and then the top of the
inch is known as the EXO trees aura
which is French for treasure which costs
$1,200 how does it all made how will
give us maybe a step-by-step but we were
to go to visit yeah the family what
would we see you'd see vineyards you
know like you're doing any other wine
region in the fall they harvest the
grapes that harvesting process is the
same as otherwise then they then they
ferment the wine as one is normally
fermented but the difference then is
that it goes through a double
distillation process in small copper
stills and and then a long period of
Aging in there quiet
sellers that are usually at high
humidity in very old barrels these are
particular barrels that are peculiar to
the cognac region and known as that
Pearson barrels and they come from the
Limousin forests and they don't use new
oak typically as much they a mellow in
these very old barrels that allow in
exchange of oxygen and tessarin is
really dedicated to this long artisanal
process and utilizing older stocks that
they've built up over these decades I
mean over a century that testerone has
been in the cognac business